they have announced the July launch of
the cbdc and that feels like as good a
deadline as any they've been killing the
crypto rails right they killed signature
they killed silvergate there aren't that
many ways out
and so what I wanted to do was say get
Bitcoin get your friends or family to
get Bitcoin get your coins off exchanges
and do that now because they might close
the doors they might bar the exit do you
know Paul Revere the printing has come
[Music]
pump
good to good to see you
um you can you can see that I'm like uh
you know
still normal guy or what have you right
um
but basically let's start here let's
start Trader uh I think a lot of people
saw you put the bed out and they're all
focused on the bet but to me the bet is
merely you sounding the alarm and so
let's go let's go back to 2020 and walk
us through what happened to get to the
point where you believe the banks are
now insolvent like how did we get here
great question so if you actually go and
you look at my
um my post on this okay so why did I do
this actually I I did not propose a bet
I accepted the BET right he he's the one
who made the BET over here number one
and number two is he did that after I
put out my initial I thought I would do
tasks and so on for people like they
would go and go and uh do tasks for
Bitcoin right but it was a good way to
this actually got 11 million views it
was good to bring attention to the key
point which is everything The Narrative
outlined in this post here and this
fortunately got 2.3 million views okay
because this is the core set of Concepts
you only read one post read this okay
I'm just going to go through it can you
see the screen
I can okay so got a post uh right here
um so this basically you know this was a
bet thread but the point of it was
actually get people to read this okay
just as in 2008 the bankers lied we
forgot
how much they had lied to us
because you know that was that was
obviously a huge thing in 2000 they
basically almost bankrupt the world
economy lying to us lying to themselves
some competence combination of greed and
competence malice or whatever blowing up
the whole world economy right this time
the central Bankers the banks and the
bank Regulators have lied to all dollar
holders and depositors it's not your
typical fractional Reserve situation
there is enough in the banks on a mark
to Market base to cover withdrawals
um I call it Uncle Sam bankman freed
okay that's actually if you want one
line just like Sam bangman freed he uh
you know he owed people let's say a
thousand Bitcoin right but when they but
and he had some balance sheet that said
his assets added up to a thousand
Bitcoin and he fooled himself or he
fooled the rest of the company or
whatever it was into thinking he
actually had that but he was actually
like gambling and all this other stuff
and he marked it at what he had when he
bought it but he didn't have it when
people came and when people actually
came he couldn't liquidate those assets
to actually get the Bitcoin that they
wanted because he had gone and gambled
it right
and uh and then of course the entire
exchange collapsed right this is
basically what has happened not just at
FTX but at all the banks all the banks
bought long-dated U.S treasuries as well
as other Bonds in 2021 they binged on
bonds as I'll show you in a second okay
they binged on bonds and um
the basically in response to the fed's
guidance here's here's the article do
you see this banks are binging on bonds
but not because they want to see this
smoking an article right from 2021 shows
enormous increase in buying of all these
bonds and less commercial loans they all
got centralized
on one guy Uncle Sam right buy bonds
even if it means skimpy profits so they
have to invest in one of the least
lucrative assets around government debt
guaranteed to produce skimpy profits
right and uh actually what happened was
basically that
um all the printed money from 2020
sloshed around the economy and it cut
off the normal flow of normal loans
because customers had you know high
levels of cash advance they normally
didn't take out loans so it broke the
banking model so all they did is they
put all this enormous amounts of cash
into bonds and when the yield on the
treasury note Rose to 1.75 Banks hungry
for higher returns rushed to buy them so
this was like 1.75 was like a high
return in 2021 August 2021 right and
moreover and that Spike didn't last
right so by the way this is all like
banking gobbledygook to many people
right but
um part of the thing about this I'll
explain the simplest terms I can right
first what you should do right what you
should do is buy Bitcoin get your coins
off exchanges and go to a crypto
friendly jurisdiction inside the us
that'll be like Florida or Texas or
something like that outside the US which
might actually be better honestly as
I'll get to would be like El Salvador
actually or UAE or
um you know uh like
Singapore and so like Western Europe but
not so much you know any basically the
closer it is to Blue America in a
network sense you know Japan is far away
from Blue America but it's very
connected to Blue America in the sense
of having lots of U.S dollar deposits
um the closer it is to Blue America in a
network sense the more it banked on the
fed and the worse off it is okay and
just to give you a sense of what
actually happened first I'll show you
some graphs okay because graphs get the
point across
um this is a graph of like how much
treasury is making look at that just
down into the right okay
this is a graph of how meaning I mean
they're losing money okay treasury the
central bank is losing money it doesn't
look like normal normal times okay
um this a graph of
uh unrealized losses
okay and this is really like the core
bomb that's blowing up this whole thing
all of these things just so people
understand the chart that we're looking
at here this is unrealized losses for
the banks the actual uh large Banks
mid-size Banks small Banks this is their
unrealized losses that are saying on the
balance sheets that they don't
necessarily have to mark to Market yeah
unless you actually come and ask for
your dollars
okay if you ask for your cash
there'll be an uncle Sam Bateman freed
situation where they don't have the
dollars on hand to make up for it but
that's what happened with Silicon Valley
Bank that's what happened with other
Banks Credit Suisse is now just admitted
as a bank run that got them and the
digital age Bank runs are very fast once
people hear that something's possibly
unsolved they all just go and pull their
money out right
and so the the whole concept of oh
they'll only ask for this much of this
time that's no longer the case you could
have everybody do an outflow at the same
time if it goes viral
on that point I think it's very
important to um to kind of understand
that what you're talking about is not
just the flow of information being fast
but you're also talking about the fact
that now for a bank run to occur you
don't have to go sit in line and stand
in line at the bank you can literally
open a new tab press a couple buttons
and move your money and so the speed of
action matches the speed of information
and that's really what's driving a lot
of these problems that's exactly right
that's exactly right and so essentially
the digital Bank Run is I mean we were
pushed into this era by the FED as I'll
get to basically
um you know these graphs okay they're
down into the right graphs they're huge
I mean this is 2008 for comparison right
these are enormous enormous yawning you
know numbers here right and here is
um
here's the Community Banks okay so this
is these are commercial Banks and this
is the Central Bank okay and then the
Community Banks here's the FED admitting
that
um you know the rising interest rates
have and again all this is in jargon
it's jargon just like you know it's like
camouflage for a sneak you know a snake
has evolved camouflage you didn't design
the camouflage but if it didn't have the
camouflage you'd be able to catch it and
kill it right so all of these words are
ways for them to hide the ball from you
fine print is not simply a tactic it's
their strategy right the you know in
2008 you they would have used mocking
terms on you they said something like
tell me you don't know what a CDO is
without telling me you don't know what a
cdos
okay and the whole point is that nobody
knows what a CD owns
now there's a guy selling another guy
buying it they're all some guys are
lying some guys are lying to themselves
some guys lying to their counterparty
sometimes you're stupid nobody asks the
obvious question of this thing isn't
worth what we think it's worth and if
you did say that I can't believe you I
mean they'd be marketing on the
portfolio so nobody wanted to believe
that until somebody poked around enough
and found actually these houses
nobody's making payments on them right
and in the same way unrealized loss is
lowering tangible actually Capital
basically what they're saying is
um at the at the end of 2021 four Banks
had you know tangible this is this thing
they've made up tangible tldr is at the
end of 2021 four Banks were insolvent by
June 30th they knew 333 of these
Community Banks were insolvent meaning
if there's an economic shock go ahead if
you came for the money the money was
gone go ahead and that comes
specifically for those that uh are
trying to understand what happened there
at the end of 2021 rates were still at
zero percent by June it was very clear
that they were hiking rates and we're
going to continue by March so yeah yeah
it was a surprise June it was very it
was very severe and it was obvious that
they were now underwater on the debt
that they had bought
yeah the thing the thing to remember is
this is like you know how in so many
other contexts right uh masks don't work
before they do
right your right-wing conspiracy
theorist blah blah if you're saying the
coronavirus is even here and you
shouldn't wear masks oh my God everybody
needs to wear a mask at all times blah
blah blah right and the science has said
this right and they just for you know
they either truly forget or they don't
want to remember they just shift like a
school of fish right uh the lab leak
obviously a conspiracy theory oh I
always had suspicions about the lab like
why wouldn't you seems like a reasonable
thing right inflation and this is a big
one right inflation see you can do that
maybe for some political stuff right
um but when you when you do it when
you're actually signing a contract at
the flip before the Flop then
everybody's screwed okay and that's what
happened essentially back when the
political class was just denying things
stop worrying about inflation right
inflation fear lurks even as officials
say not to worry Powell dollar plays
inflation risk is yelling foreshadows
future spending right and then
like this okay so you know again if
people are watching this don't need to
know how interest rates work but
essentially what they did was they faked
out everybody
everybody's making long-term plans they
said inflation was a conspiracy theory
it's not real you buy 10-year bonds that
denial continued through 2021 then the
rates just got hiked super fast in one
year higher than 10 Years everybody
who's a bondholder got destroyed
including SUV by many others all by the
fed this is what happened right
everybody who trusted the FED everybody
who made essentially a long-term bet in
2021 on the the the full faith and
credit of the US government on the
Financial Health 10-year bond supposed
to be a stable country it's not supposed
to go way way up and down like this
right
um they got destroyed absolutely
destroyed basically in a sense if you
still thought America was the same
country in mid 2021 and you still kept
doing what you were doing then you
weren't doing the right thing
clearly the country had just permanently
changed right even if you know like what
had happened before in 2020 with the
crazy riots and so forth all of that now
became the government
and so that kind of went now it's it's
like swallowing the poison right and so
everybody you know the form may have
been the same but the substance are now
totally different right and um you know
so I said like inflation is a case where
yesterday's conspiracy theory became
today's conventional wisdom the issue is
all kinds of contracts got see you know
a lot of folks claiming that svb was a
victim of the industry they weren't that
big and they weren't in shock the thing
is this is just either it's either
delusional or it's wrong or it's
whatever but you know as I mentioned
over here even Janet Yellen
has admitted that uh the high interest
rate environment basically that caused
people to lose market value I mean duh
right and everybody's like oh why don't
you just hedge interest rate risk well
because you can hedge if it goes from
like point one percent to one point one
percent you can't hedge if it's point
one percent it goes to 4.75 it just
completely destroys all of your
projections so just showing you that
um
but I'm going to jump out of the banker
stuff in a second because as I said the
whole point of it is it's been naturally
selected to be very confusing and to not
know where things are right but but
basically just to give you a sense they
project in December 2020 there's going
to be 0.1 forever right everybody who's
trying to make long-term decisions is
buying long-term bonds and then oh my
God it's actually a 4.75 in 2023
you know I'm now I'm totally crushed
right because the rate totally changed
and you can see actually a record of
their forecasts and how they change over
time now the thing about this is
to understand these forecasts billions
and billions and billions of dollars are
based on them and when they wiggle like
this because they're such conformists
that they go up and down and up and down
right when they wiggle at that extent it
like whiplashes the entire economy and
causes all kinds of things to break and
chatter and so on because all these
Pension funds and all these things that
buy it on their guidance trust them and
then they all go off a cliff at the same
time like Lemmings and that's basically
what happened so it's coming back up the
stack
um you know here we are so basically
they all knew this huge crash was coming
okay so all the stuff on interest rates
and so on
um you don't have to worry about that
too much I mean it's it's kind of the
back story to this right but the main
point is the banks central banks the
banks and banking regulars all knew a
huge Crashers coming the phrases
unrealized losses but they never
notified you the depositor instead they
allow The Regulators allowed Banks to
hide their literal insolvency and
footnotes until one guy figured it out
okay and so here just take a look at
this ready one two three four five six
seven I guess and the only one using
Twitter blue to its fullest when I saw
you use this I literally said Twitter
blue was made for Balaji footnotes this
is amazing right so because I'm not like
this is not oh you some crazy guy just
saying this blah blah I have names and
dates and specific links in their
archive so I'm just going to show you
five links that show that the central
bank which is a fed the banks and the
banking Regulators all new huge crash
was coming but they never notified you
the depositor instead they allowed Banks
to hide their literal insolvency and
footnotes until somebody figured it out
okay so link number one here's the FED
okay all the banks are insolvent
333 Community Banks versus four over
here okay and by the way people will be
like oh how'd they hide it huh they
publish it on the web that's really
hiding it right it's called you know
well you call it hiding in played site
or you could say all right did they tell
the depositors the millions of like
Republicans and so on that the banks had
lost their money you know that that the
FED had told the banks to lose their
money did you notify the depositors
publishing this coded kind of thing on
their website does not say in plain
English that if you came for your
dollars it would not be there right
so it's not it's like a non-disclosure
disclosure right here's another one you
know FDIC worried about growing
unrealized loss in Banks portfolios it's
a very substantial overhang it could
impact our institutions it's 400 billion
dollars I mean it's starting to be real
money right okay and
um and it's because the FED raised rates
okay then here
is that same guy FDIC chair just two or
three days before svb saying unrealized
loss is weak and a future bank's ability
to meet economic needs right
um the total was 620 billion dollars
right and uh you know just just
absolutely gigantic numbers okay here
the FED itself okay in fed minutes
February 23. again this stuff is written
it's like verbally encrypted you know
it's like ostensibly disclosed but it's
not the effect of large unrealized
losses on Bank security portfolios so
they did know that you know basically
you know Powell the day later right went
in you know on March 7th he went and
testified to Congress on March 6 was
this FDIC thing March 17 Winchester
Congress and um
he said something to the effect of that
the banks were solve it right but the
FED lie Banks died right that's
basically you know if you want to get to
the core of it once basically the the
FED had basically passed off see the FED
raised these rates and the value of
bonds Banks uh owned dropped what
happened was all the banks panicked
they're like oh crap we all listen to
the FED we all went and uh they all went
and binged on bonds okay and uh you know
here's where is it there's binging on
bonds they listened to the Fed
they binged on bonds they all got
destroyed at the same way at the same
time and then what did they do they're
like what should they do in reaction to
the large losses right like you know the
resulting impact on Capital they're
scared the FED had just surprised them
and just destroyed their entire
portfolio right anxious Bankers
wondering what they should do and so
they decided to do is transfer
Securities to HTM okay what the heck is
HDM
um oh it's uh it's basically like hold
to maturity it's basically like
sambachman free going and buying
something it gets marked down 60 but he
says it's still worth what it was it's
like your nft you still think it's worth
a million dollars no it's not worth a
million dollars okay no one's gonna pay
you a million dollars for it but you
hold to maturity oh actually no sorry
it's a little different than that people
always will own the technology oh no
it's an nft that will return that pays
you one percent each year and it will
return a million dollars in you know
eight or nine more years but if you uh
but today there's another one that you
can buy for the same amount that returns
you five percent each year or whatever
and so your one is worth way less by
comparison they'll always want to be
like oh that specific typo or you know
like slight imprecision but the
substance of it is that they did some
accounting magic to hide their gigantic
losses and um this was true at many
different banks like svb also did this
evidence of deception by SV management
where
um they used to have a very clean line
showing those Securities then they made
it you know reserved reserved right and
then suddenly oh ta-da 491.8 like
basically they The Regulators allowed
the bank to hide their literal
insolvency in a footnote
okay oh yeah you know we just moved
things around 81.6 billion dollars not a
big 81.6 billion dollars more than the
GP a small country put in a footnote and
this is what set up the situation where
um some engineer
at you know Dropbox or whatever you know
like some you know some employee of some
tech company
goes to work one day finds that their
company's bank account the money is gone
and some American Bank that they thought
they could trust for you know 40 years
and wanting their business checking
account back is blamed on them right
like think about you know how insane
that is and I was like how could that
possibly have happened right and and one
of the things that's going on here by
the way is you know how um if you're you
know in San Francisco right you pay for
all the police and get none of the
protection okay it's what's called a
narco tyranny okay so that's like uh
you're you're an Uber driver and you're
in San Francisco and uh you get a 200
300 parking ticket okay for doing
nothing but the guy who smashes your
window and and you know Wilds down the
street nothing happens to them okay so
it's a tyranny and the Anarchy at the
same time right similarly this is like
an archet Journey but for banks where
somehow the money can be gone overnight
that's the Anarchy but the Tyranny is
five thousand why the heck is this
stupid I mean all these forms and all
this verbiage there but the regulator
doesn't know that the bank is insolvent
didn't warn depositors you find out in a
bank run with all of these filings that
was that was I was trying to figure out
how when did this actually happen and
then I pulled on that and I pulled on
that and I pulled on that until I could
add up what I was seeing in front of me
and I was like they're all dead
this is just the first bank that floated
up to the surface all the banks are dead
and they're just going to keep coming up
and so you know that's why I tweeted
this and nobody else there was like uh
you know March 11th as soon as I kind of
I got on this like a dog on a bone
because I was like how the heck could a
200 billion dollar Bank go to zero like
this and I was like oh that wasn't a
unique cause of them as treasury because
everybody's trying to blame it on how
they did Risky VC bets and so no they
bought treasuries which was like
supposedly the safest ass in the world
right and so even on March like 11th
right I was like
where we'd like to see in the coming
weeks it wasn't a single Bank issues a
central bank issue right most banks are
suffering unrealized losses thanks to
Rapid change and people are like no no
you're trying to make special eating
right and there's all kinds of weird
optical illusions that people have in
this space they like worship the FED oh
my God I can't believe you're blaming
the FED they think of the FED as like
like a god or the referee or something
where you're not the wizard
yeah exactly and you know the thing is I
this kind of stuff always bored me
frankly because I was you know it's it's
like it's kind of meant it's a lot of
money for sure but it's also written in
such a ways to be boring and
complex but point being though that
um this was 10 days ago I was like you
know we're gonna not a single bank issue
central bank issue that was that was
basically
um that was before so you know they they
basically we now have five banks dad
right they're silvergate there's
um signature there's svb there's First
Republic and there's Credit Suisse and
some of them are dead and some of them
are murdered right but uh clearly it's
not a single thing and moreover the new
wsja dozens of banks
may have risk to some similar still
coming back 186 Banks and maybe prone
similarious who knows if it's 186 or if
it's
333 or if it's
um you know like many or in this case
he's like uh you know I always say he
says most banks like what is the exact
number of dead Banks who knows okay but
what happened after the SUV thing was
found out is the Fed moved into because
I think they were trying to figure they
were trying to hope that there would
never be a bankrupt or something like
SBF no one would ever come looking for
their money right
yeah real quick before uh before we get
into what happened with the FED kind of
stepping in what I want to also just
call out very quickly is that a huge
part of this was all of the stimulus all
of the quantitative easing all the
bailouts all all of this stuff that
happened between 2020 and it's called
2022. one of the key things that uh
people focused on was inflation the rise
of prices that people were paying
attention there but I had an aha as I
was reading your tweets and kind of
looking at more of it is like guess
where all of that money ended up
regardless of if an individual or a
corporation had it it ended up in a bank
and so it was a deposit somewhere right
if I received a 1200 check and I turn on
I give it to a business that business
puts it in a bank it's a deposit and so
the quote-unquote big Winners throughout
2020 and 2021 was the bank deposits
growing at hundreds of percent which
then basically now put them in a
position where they had to figure out
what do we do with all these new
deposits and that's really kind of what
led to them buying these long duration
bonds because of the zero interest rate
environment put them all at massive risk
and so we get to the failure of svb and
maybe you can explain kind of what the
fed and kind of other organizations are
doing by stepping in here
yeah so so basically
um I mean it goes back even further
right because you know if people have
known like the US is living on borrowed
time for a long time you know that it's
been printing so much money it said like
it's a zombie economy for a while right
um you know bail out of GM bail out of
this right all kinds of things just got
tons of money to stay afloat and you
know for example like the Marvel reruns
you know all that type of stuff where
um you have 75 80 year old presidents
you know all of that stuff right so you
can you can pull it back to the pandemic
you can pull it back to the financial
crisis you can pull it back probably
further than that you know and uh
there's probably steps that people could
have taken at any one given moment
um but specifically with the pandemic
yeah you're correct that huge amounts of
money sloshed onto the balance sheet of
banks they had to do something with it
everybody else also had lots of money
they weren't taking out loans so the
banks also did think maybe in is going
to come but they knew the Fed was
denying that they were going to hike
raids so they're like okay fine
um we're going to just instead
um buy these crappy bonds we've got now
and get these 10 years and then when
Powell hydrates so fast so quickly
nobody could find a counterparty for
their huge born bound portfolio because
they're all in the same boat at the same
time because expressing different
opinions all these Lemmings just went
off a cliff and everybody was just
hoping that the FED would eventually
pivot right and now they have because
after svb they've decided okay rather
than having people just go and withdraw
you know their money and cause a bank
run now instead we're going to just
print money behind every depositor F fed
DIC Insurance okay
and so now the game now it's now we're
an end game okay because now what
they've done what that is is it's a
stealth monetization of the debt all all
the debts that they owe they have now
just magic them away and they don't want
to call it that but one of the clever
things is that these bondholders
um
now they they are so happy to have their
losses deleted by the FED that they're
probably not realizing that the amount
of money injected into the system like
for example you buy a billion dollar
Bond okay you just lost 15 on it or
something like that and the FED says you
know I'm gonna value so it's it's 850
million oh crap
the FED says you know what I'm going to
still value that at a billion and it was
btfp program they're like the markdown
didn't happen and they do something
complicated it's not exactly buying at
some loan kind of thing but the the
point of it though is
um that you got your your billion and
rather than your 850 million you got
that extra money to 150 you know and so
you're feeling happy at that time and I
don't know what the exact contracts are
that they signed but that bank that you
know was killed by the fed and now saved
by the FED is happy but I wouldn't be
surprised if they signed something that
says oh you can't accuse us of it being
a sovereign default
but now ta-da
they have managed to get people to eat
that Sovereign default
and now they just hope that basically
the level of inflation that's in the
system where they've just increased the
money supply so dramatically
is not something that's going to flow
into Bitcoin
and and like I know everything I'm
saying here just sounds like really
complicated and intricate and like hard
to track or whatever but the tldr is
imagine if Sam bankman freed he had
these assets you know he he owed you a
thousand Bitcoin people came back and
you only had
400 Bitcoin and he had assets that he
thought were worth 600 Bitcoin
um you couldn't sell those to get 600
Bitcoin but then suddenly in comes the
government and issues him stuff over
here new Bitcoins and he could give them
back that won't work for Bitcoin because
you can't print Bitcoin the 21 million
limit is actually it's such a simple but
important hard constraint on the entire
system right
whereas with the FED they can swoop in
behind the scenes and start printing
dollars such that these guys can make
good on their obligations right and that
is what has happened where there's
essentially like both domestic and
international balance now by the way
just to take temperature
um on a one to a ten uh you know I
should probably tweet this do you are
you aware or do you believe that a
financial crisis is happening
I'm the wrong person to ask because I
know that we not only uh are going to
have a financial crisis I know that we
are in one and it is way more drastic
than most people realize hence why I'm
spending so much time talking about this
right exactly that's right so this is
the stealth financial crisis that's
actually why see because nyt and others
they're all pointing your attention at
something else they're not front paging
this intentionally because they don't
want you to panic Don't Panic whatever
you do you know like remember FTX is
fine assets are fine right that's
exactly what's happening now Treasury
and and you know uh fed have statements
out saying we're solvent money is there
don't worry you know all the banks are
good full faith and credit blah blah
blah and of course when you have to put
that statement out that's obviously when
um things are going good
you know
so what I again the simple version of
what I think happens there could be a
lot of twists and turns is it's really
going to be one of two things
first
um
lots of there's all kinds of chaotic
Printing and Bank runs and so on in the
weeks to come as worry depositors check
on their funds
and the Big Branch point is whether they
wire it to Big Banks
or where they turn into Bitcoin
and that determines basically where
they're literally like where their
freedom lives as funny as that sounds
okay because if everybody wires to Big
Banks
then and they think oh my God the FED
saved us the big Bank saved us and all
the small Banks and all the tech Banks
and so on die
well the FED now cbdc which they chose
by the way to announce even in the
middle of this crisis okay they
announced on March 15th it's going to
come out in July okay
then
all the money is trapped at all the big
Banks
and then in July you only have like four
Banks left or whatever it is
the cbdc is rolled out and too big to
fail becomes like too big to escape
you literally can't spend your money
without government approval on anything
oh you want to buy that BP nope that guy
is bad that person you can very
fine-grained pulling of every single
transaction anybody's ever done you
can't exit the system it is like it
becomes like uh you go from a free
person to having Monopoly points on
somebody's computer it's even more than
I mean the FED system has become more
like that even you know right and
whoever they don't like they delete them
whenever they like they they add them
and the whole cbdc basically makes all
kinds of monkeying around with
individual people's balances much easier
to do right and that is what China
certainly do right so anybody who's
politically unfavorable to the regime
they freeze they could seize they can
spy they can do whatever right and it
was politically favorable they just
direct deposit somebody else's money and
nobody can see it right
so um
you know it and then of course it can
cut off inter-convertibility into
cryptocurrency they just won't let
somebody buy or sell it for that or at
least not without without knowing about
it
um
and you can imagine maybe OTC trades
were the second part of that you know
like the the BTC part of it isn't shown
but they won't like it right so so the
current path before setting up the bit
signal was something where and again how
intentional is it versus how emergent I
don't know but the current path was uh
that the FED causes this crisis
bankrupts all the banks
um you know one of them has a bankrupt
and fed rolls in they're both arsonist
and firefighter somehow they know
exactly what's about to happen right
FDIC enrolled in real they're real
professionals right actually they they
knew the bank their thing was insolvent
right and um
then what happened was
um
that uh with all these small Banks the
tech Banks Community Banks going down
and all the money pinned at the Central
Bank uh or at the big Banks
um the cbdc rollout becomes very simple
you just have four Banks and really all
the same and now you don't have any
choice
and the alternative to that though is if
people buy Bitcoin that is literally the
exit from the system it is something
that they cannot control they cannot
edit the entries on that ledger that the
whole point is this bulletproof
decentralized Ledger and uh the 21
million number they can't corrupt it and
they can't censor it and
um this whole thing everything that
we've ever talked about here you know
you and me for 10 years and you know
what's funny is
um I am not in either of us I don't
think you know I'm not a Bitcoin Maximus
but we're all going to be Bitcoin
maximalist now okay what I mean by that
is
the Bitcoin maximum is philosophy and
again I recognize that many of its
exponents and so on are like insane and
CR it's all true but unfortunately
you're going to kind of need insane
people for what is about to happen Okay
their worldview is the closest most
people most of our people don't have any
idea of what's coming okay the Bitcoin
Maximus are maybe the only people on
Earth who are prepared for the potential
Sovereign default of the US dollar and
the rise of Bitcoin and the constant of
hyper bitcoinization where the reserve
currency switches over to BTC and all
Fiat around the world like basically
collapses relative to the hardest money
around right and basically what the what
the US has done what the FED has done is
caused the Fiat crisis it's not really
just a banking crisis it's a Fiat crisis
because the crisis of having everything
centralized in one place and them all
screwing it up in the same way at the
same time and lying to everybody with
uncheckable things every single thing
that the most intense Bitcoin maximalist
would say you know for example I posted
that Meme of you know you could sell
your Bitcoin for Millions someday he's
like Neo when you're ready you won't
have to right because like selling for a
trillion Zimbabwe dollars right so hyper
bitcoinization which is the simultaneous
rise of Bitcoin and transition to
reserve currency in the crash or other
Fiats against it is going to be a huge
mess
um because I think it's going to come
much faster than people think because
with all this printed money we've got
about three months before this cbdc gets
out there where you're still a free man
you know and you might be able to wire
it out and you might be able to turn
some of it into BTC and hold that
locally and that is basically the way
like that is a way that we might
preserve some degree of freedom on the
other side of this because either it's a
go ahead I know that sounds see I don't
normally talk like that
so I think a key question and uh uh I
should blame you because once you put
out this bit signal I have somehow
become a half spokesperson for Balaji I
literally have gone on podcasts and
they're asking me what is Balaji doing I
have no clue so I figured you could
explain for yourself but the other thing
is in private there's people who uh I
think follow your work and they're like
look blashy usually doesn't have this
type of language Boston usually isn't
you know this public in terms of some of
the things that he believes and so that
makes them pay attention when you made
the bet the one million dollar bitcoin
price in 90 days help unpack in that bet
are you saying hyperinflation in the
United States or are you saying no when
they're hyperinflational or not people
are going to start to exit and therefore
they are going to buy Bitcoin and it
will push the price to a million dollars
in 90 day period like how do you think
about let's go through kind of if your
vision of what is about to happen occurs
what does that world look like over the
next 90 days
what I think is either so the reason I
did the BET was to get people to the
Bitcoin Lifeboat
buy Bitcoin get your keys off exchanges
get to a Bitcoin friendly jurisdiction
that is the message buy Bitcoin get your
keys off changes get to a Bitcoin
friendly jurisdiction
um everything else I say is a rationale
for that right but that's what the
message I'm getting out there is I'm
basically burning money to do this it is
not something that I mean the thing is I
believe in Bitcoin but I also believe in
the public good and that's going to be
something that's insured Supply and what
follows if what I'm saying is correct
and I believe it is that the central
banks and the and like the US government
has betrayed people on this level right
such that they just
blew up huge amounts of people savings
okay and you couldn't even trust the
banks I mean like obviously you knew you
can trust the banks quote unquote in
2008 but the degree to which you know
it's like the South Park episode you
know hey it's gone right you know that
thing right that's that's what we were
talking about or or like you know South
American kind of Bank you trust the
South American Bank maybe in this
Century you do you know the flipping
just like it was from like Russia to
China like China's now the senior
partner we're from Britain to India
India's not a student part it's quite
possible that in this Century it's like
this is South America's time shine
because they understand currency crises
they understand the value of Bitcoin El
Salvador you know his model is now
something that you could export over you
know South America you could have you
know who knows what happens in what
follows I actually think but Kelly
becomes a pretty important person in the
world actually
um El Salvador might become one of the
richest countries in the world with with
all the Bitcoin they've got if this
happens okay
um
but but basically what I did was uh most
people were not this financial crisis
was creeping up like a like a panther or
like a like a cloud enveloping people
they weren't even aware of it it was
just invested so much in stealth mode
that whether you know people are just
sleepwalking it just wasn't a topic of
conversation and so on now this is
something that's cut through the noise
and everybody is aware that there is a
financial crisis on
and that the banks don't have your money
and the money is gone right and that you
should probably exchange some of it into
Bitcoin and you should do that sooner
rather than later
because
um you don't know
we all don't know it's just hard to
predict timing on anything but they have
announced the July launch of the cbdc
and that feels like as good a deadline
as any they've been killing the crypto
rails right they killed signature they
killed silvergate there aren't that many
ways out
and so what I wanted to do was say get
Bitcoin get your friends or family to
get Bitcoin get your coins off exchanges
and do that now because they might close
the doors they might borrow the exit now
the thing is the good thing is they
won't be able to borrow worldwide
because the US doesn't have control over
all banks worldwide anymore there's like
UAE and Saudi and so on but they still
do have control over quite a big chunk
of it and uh you know one way of
thinking about it is you know I was born
an American and I
um I I'm doing this because I actually
love American values you know Paul
Revere the printing is coming
right the printing is coming that's
literally what we're talking about right
the printing is coming this is a you
know another American analogy this is a
digital Pearl Harbor on all dollar
holders the dollar holder is a bag
holder okay and I mean that literally
you know what's funny is you know I the
funny thing about this is I sound now
like the most intense maximalist ever
right
I don't know what yeah you do but but
the reason why I'm laughing is because
uh what you're saying is actually very
little to do with Bitcoin right like you
are basically looking at the traditional
Financial system and you are saying
there are major problems here and I
don't give a if you care about
Bitcoin or you don't care about Bitcoin
but you have to identify what the
problems are and then make the decisions
for yourself oh by the way I the lodge
you believe that Bitcoin is the best
solution but some other people may go
buy real estate or buy whatever asset
that they think is better but first you
have to get them to identify the problem
before they even begin to think about a
potential solution
I know but even then I think yes the
reason I'm saying Bitcoin and as I said
I have a maximal is for now for the for
like for digital wartime right Bitcoin
only and the reason is that real estate
and other kinds of things like that
um maybe Real Estate in Red States I
guess but lots and lots of Fiat stuff is
you know what happened to the Russians
or the Canadian truckers right their
stuff yes they're just seized right so I
have a feeling that as these Banks all
melt down right the most trustworthy
things out there I mean your your
business checking account is insecure
and if you want it back that's a bailout
right these kind of crazy stuff which
what it does by the way see a normal
Predator when it walks up to you like or
it's running at you it looks got fangs
and sharp and you're like oh and then
you you know you fight back against and
you have legitimate self-defense imagine
a predator that like could
you know anesthetize you you know like a
mosquito in a sense and it sucks your
blood and you don't even know it's there
right
um that's kind of like these these
Finance Guys these Bankers who will take
your money and tell you're bad for
resisting you know they're like you know
again it's it's something where National
selection operates at many different
levels obviously it operates at the
level of the physical invisible kind of
thing but also operates at the level of
ideologies and even business practices
right if
um if they had not adopted those kinds
of things then
um
they would be more easily spotted oh
yeah well this says send all my money to
so-and-so place no thank you very much
right and so the funny thing is all
kinds of maximalist impulses like
distrusting contracts distrusting you
know complicated things I want simple
things like lots of those impulses are
going to be good impulses in what
follows you know like a minimum
necessary complexity
um we're basically the whole
de-financialization of this gigantic
kind of thing may happen actually really
fast as tons of banks go down and so on
and we'll see what happens right
talk a little bit about yeah talk a
little bit about the speed at which this
has happened previously so you know for
example I know somebody uh who lived in
a country where there was hyperinflation
it literally happened in 60 days right
it went from everything's fine to Bam
hundreds of percent of inflation explain
a little bit as to why you think this uh
kind of combination of historical
hyperinflation and the speed at which it
happens combine lined with what I call
the digital catastrophe right this kind
of speed of information and action can
then almost accelerate at an even faster
pace
that's right so first is hyperinflation
table right this look at the speed of
this this is hours to days right it's
really really really really really
really really fast okay
um second is the digital bank run right
so
um here is actually
right social media driven Bank Run kill
Credit Suisse 10 billion in a day 12th
deposit svb collapse from asset size of
five billion CEO blames Twitter right
social media rumor okay so
um so basically digital Bank runs are
they're not built for that all
Dodd-Frank assumes people come in in
person right so the system isn't set up
for something from this angle right
um so one is that high reflection two is
third is just look at you know some of
these stocks right First Republic Bank
here look this was this was like pretty
legit paying for a long time seemingly
right
um look at that
look at that is that
see it's continuous and it looked
thought they were getting really rich
and then dead
right everybody knew that this was fake
but it's like kind of accelerating your
entire life and then ending it
that's what the FED did you know it's
like just just look at that what that
felt like going from that to that right
that's the printing and that's the you
know rate hiking and like you know I'm
not saying this is normal business cycle
but they went bananas in the you know
just you know so the thing is that's
First Republic all right here is uh you
know Silicon Valley Bank
right look at that again it's continuous
and it's just digital and dead at the
end okay here is
um the the so-called uh the so-called
discount window
and again they make all this stuff you
know give all these various names so
look at this this looks like
here's another thing it's like you know
there's like some little wrig holes and
so on then that's 2008 this is Corona
discount window is already just far
beyond anything there's a little bit of
you know kind of thing this is just does
that look like a normal graph
no of course not and then also I think
that there there's another piece to this
whole thesis that um hasn't really been
called out a lot it's like the central
Bankers learned a playbook in 2008 they
perfected it during uh coronavirus 2020
and now it's like they're in the big
leagues And when they see that fat you
know fastball coming down the middle of
the plate they can swing with all their
might and so as you see in this chart
here like they're swinging they just
gave back a third of everything they
sold off their balance sheet in a year
they give it back in literally one week
half I think it's half
half of all the QT in one right that's
this is the last screenshot who knows it
said like it's like 5xf right now who
knows right
um and and they also by the way they
they uh they lie like they breathe right
because every single thing they say you
have to like translate fed speak where
it's like you know they they lie in
certain ways where if you're um you know
uh I'll give a great example like um
okay look at this right March 12th we're
only going to print 25 billion now it's
2 trillion four days later how about
that and it's actually but it actually
is infinity
right
and uh so so you know this graph no
longer
looks that crazy anymore relative to the
discount window stuff right like these
um you know they look the same and the
thing is everybody's known that this was
going to happen one of the I think one
of my contributions in all of this is
reframing this as not like some Tech
Guys thing or whatever but as like the
final Big Deck crisis that Dalia
predicted right everybody knew this
would come
but not exactly how and when and the FED
didn't have strategic surprise but had
tactical surprise and again whether it's
a intentional or emergent doesn't matter
right tldr is they are now doing that
digital devaluation of the dollar and so
now what's going to happen I think is
now the fire alarm has been rung
um hopefully you have something where
only dollar holders pay for the sins of
the dollar
okay so everybody because I think
there's multiple tribes in the US
there's blue tribe red tribe great tribe
like Sky Alexander's foreign tribes
right so hopefully
everybody who doesn't fully trust the
banks in the US government Hedges into
Bitcoin to a greater and greater extent
um and we'll see exactly how that
manifests and then they'll have like you
know they'll print so much that probably
prices of you know bread and other kinds
of things will go up versus the dollar
and that's when you know things start to
get pretty nasty right
um but we'll see what happens uh I mean
the big thing is by the way you go back
and watch this video
dalio has cartoons in there and he does
that it's very well done but it means
that you feel like it's something
happening to people at a far away time
and place and people don't panic or
freak out or whatever
but then watch those and then replace
those cartoons with the assets going to
zero and people being in conflict with
like real photos in your head and it
feels very different you know what I
mean it's like no one cares today about
the collapse of the Dutch or whatever
because that was hundreds of years ago
it's a different thing when it's like
happening to you you know
let me pause there
so I have a couple of questions that uh
now that people understand you know how
we got here what the FED is doing what
you think will happen kind of moving
forward
um maybe the first place to start is you
said this a couple of days ago now I
have had people across Tech Finance
Bitcoin you know crypto World whatever
reach out to me and ask some version of
is blushy serious what is he thinking do
you agree with him what percentage
likelihood do you think it is whatever
from your standpoint have you had people
from the traditional Financial World
reach out to better understand this or
is it still an internet thing and it's
basically the community of people who
know you from the Internet or have you
now started to have this narrative and
this uh kind of idea seep into the
traditional Financial world where people
are starting to pay attention so I'm
aware that several large billionaires
have started buying Bitcoin no not
started like like have
they see the thing is this set of facts
that I put together over here
is a like this is not crazy right this
is a set of Highly this is a
well-documented essay
with links graphs and charts that
makes sense it tells a story that makes
sense that predicts both past I mean
like that that makes sense of Pass
events and predicts future events and it
puts all the pieces together as to what
happened and why it happened and what's
going to happen
and it leads to a terrifying conclusion
which is all the banks are dead and
we're going to find out One bank right
at a time like what they've what they've
decided to do is to monetize the debt in
the most chaotic Way by having it be
first come first served okay they print
tons of money
and all the banks have your money but
the only person who has a purchasing
power is a person who turns into Bitcoin
first
that's it
right the parsing power is being eroded
silently with this print right and um
because this is like the last print you
know they've just they have monetized
the debt so insofar as I made a
contribution it was that and it's your
to your question yes uh I mean like
there's a zillion people who called and
messaged or whatever and all I've done
is I've said you know the first thing
they're like are you know some people
actually the people who know me know
that I'm not I've you know you know I
mean for I don't know five years ten
years something something in that range
right I'm not a John McAfee kind of guy
right there's there's only one other
time I've ever rung the fire alarm and
that like on this level and that was
early covet and the reason I did it then
was the same reason did now is because I
took the hit of having being like you
know execrated for weeks as a racist
blah blah blah oh my God you're such a
racist for saying it's coming from China
like this kind of insane stuff you know
oh my God you know you're still paranoid
at the time by the way and here's the
thing about about covet today in 2023
people believe two things number one
China had a virus that leaked out of a
lab that infected more than 700 million
people worldwide and killed seven
million of them sickening tens of
millions of others and they covered it
up and that's so terrible and it's bad
true of course you know NIH actually
also funded China so like the US was
also involved it's like this terrible
kind of thing right the gain of function
research
and number two it wasn't that big a deal
life went on Cove it's up right so now
the thing is I actually agree with both
the statements but at the time in early
2020 if you go back and look at the
number of deaths it was growing
exponentially like that and nobody's
paying any attention to it and as an
empirical question that it managed to
top out at about 7 000 deaths per day
rather than like seventy thousand right
so
I you know like if you go back and look
at my tweeting I basically stopped
tweeting about it around the time they
started saying oh
you know race relate you know was it
racism is a real pandemic or some
something you know insane like that
right remember the riots and so on once
people just started going losing their
minds I did not tweet about anymore what
I wanted to alert people to was this was
a real thing the problem is that while
the tech you know and of course people
will argue about this so one thing I'll
find is
there's a lot of people who believe both
that the China super yield for letting
this leak out of a lab and it's just the
flu it wasn't a big deal it was not just
a flu it just it was a novel virus that
killed a lot of people right we uh you
know I uh you can argue about which
vaccines are good and you know so on I
think probably what it is is that
getting covered was so bad that a
vaccine that gives some percentage of
people similar effects to covid it's as
if they were infected with covid and
it's at larger scale that is my rough
belief right so that it's probably uh
better to get um the vaccine that's good
but I know that people will defer this
and argue in this and so I'm not here to
litigate that what I am here to say is
that the early stages of covid
I think that there absolutely was
something happening and there were a lot
of changes that were going to happen and
that's what I kind of flagged right
um
as for now I think this is going to be
something similar where this is
something that uh the full consequences
of lots of you know Western Banks being
dead uh lots of money being printed and
a cbdc and a lot of consolidation in CBC
I don't know exactly what they're going
to be but they could be even worse in
some ways because if you have a CDC
you just can't get your money out ever
maybe right depending on how much level
of control is you may not ever be able
to get it out
and if you can't ever get it out they
might not let you buy a plane ticket
they meant there's so many things that
they would do to people who were
politically disfavored without saying
anything
that uh it would be pretty pretty nasty
right anyway let me pause there all
right the next question that a bunch of
people when I told them we were going to
do this uh were asking me is what is
your best argument for why you're wrong
or what is your best argument for why
the US dollar will not inflate away and
it will continue to be the global
Reserve currency the best argument for
so I actually don't think all right well
um
let's do a few what's my best argument
for why I'm wrong I think the best
argument for why I'm wrong is probably
that this will happen but it'll be over
a longer time scale
and won't be that fast and this is not
the final crisis but it's the
precursor to the final crisis or the you
know the final crash will be in a few
years or something right something about
it feels different though
and the reason it feels different is
it's a consumer facing crisis
in the sense of all the previous ones
were Enterprise crises you know like you
just read in the news that Bankers were
worried and anxious and sweating and so
on you didn't have 40 000 companies and
all of their employees all at the same
time completely panicking that they that
their entire life's work would go to
zero because you know supposedly they're
you know like
and it was blamed on them you know like
that that you didn't have something like
that right that is something that causes
a fundamental distrust in the U.S
banking system Moody's downgraded the
banking system in many ways America is
already Argentina okay now so why am I
wrong if I'm wrong I'm wrong because it
takes longer for inflation to propagate
out than I think because I think now
they have printed so much money that
it's a matter of time
but I want to be wrong in a sense
because uh and I'll probably post this
when I post to bed like I hope I don't
win
okay in that sense because
um
what this is is a way to call attention
to this stealth financial crisis
and you know it's like prepping you know
it's like buying a gun or whatever you
hope you don't have to use it
but you better be prepared because you
might
you know so buying Bitcoin and getting
to a jurisdiction that is Bitcoin
friendly that has you know Texas GOP has
this thing shall not be infringed right
the right to buy sales and receive
Bitcoin challenge Mississippi Montana
they have right to mind bills Tennessee
Wyoming have the Dow laws obviously
Florida you know is pro-bitcoin
um and I kind of think will happen is a
potential dividing line in the not too
distant future will be there'll be
states that don't blue states that don't
allow individuals to hold Bitcoin Only
The Government Can like gun bans right
and red states that allow individuals to
hold Bitcoin
and I think that's going to be now of
course when I say Bitcoin maybe it's
lightning or something like that you
know we all that is to be figured out
obviously transactions volumes all those
stuff that's important
um
and uh anyways there's way more I could
say but let me let me stop there
so when you mentioned Bitcoin and kind
of uh you know Second Amendment uh it
makes me think of Jason Lowry and the
thesis around like the software and
basically Bitcoin being this you know
projection of power
um and something that the United States
uh should go ahead and embrace given the
existing financial situation it is it
your recommendation that the Central
Bank should immediately go buy Bitcoin
as a hedge against their own devaluation
of the fiatrics or do you think they
would never ever ever ever ever do that
just these guys being with it it's it
they have an economic theory that could
not predict the existence of Bitcoin
and I mean really what that that's what
this is it is do you trust Powell or
Satoshi
that's literally what this is right
um and you know people said you know the
FED is more powerful than the president
and so on if Bitcoin becomes the global
Reserve currency that is a changing of
the order it is a different it is a
different world after that right so they
would never
um they would never maybe I don't know I
doubt it I've never seen a central
Banker that likes Bitcoin
um there's some that understand it but
they don't like it because it's the one
thing that they can't manipulate on
their keyboard so one thing they can't
seize or freeze you know they're almost
like a video game developer points here
points there and so on except there's
consequences in the real world you know
you can make a game more interesting by
adding certain points but making people
dance in the real world you know by just
sloshing numbers around the spreadsheet
is is not fun right for the person who's
having to dance in such a way like these
people who are faked out by all rates
are going to be low rates whoa rates are
so high and they all just crash
gigantic pile of bodies at the base of
that Cliff you know
um
so no I I think you know I haven't read
Laurie's thing I saw it online I think
the basic issue by with a lot of those
guys who I like is that they just have a
romantic image in their head I mean
the thing is you don't think for my
network State book like God State and
Network
it's like yes what is leviathan right
what is the highest power and a lot of
philosophies actually reduced to this
even unconsciously is the highest power
almighty God
is it the you know the military the
state like the US military or the
Chinese military if you're in China
or is it encryption
right
and uh the thing is that
I think a lot of people
just still project onto the current U.S
government what it was as opposed to
what it is you know it's like it's been
silently corrupted in some ways not that
silent actually but it has the same flag
and it has the same this it's got It's
like
um you know Scott Alexander talks about
the skin suit wearer
right like something kills something and
wears its skin you know so it's got the
skin of the old America
but the substance is like some Demon
that's inhabited it and you know that
has gotten all the banks to tell you
that it's your fault if the money is
gone right and
um
you know by the way all these FDIC
things you know like you used to have
like small Bank bankruptcies you didn't
used to have like gigantic 100 billion
dollar banks with no warning go
absolutely to zero right that's new
that's like not you know that's it 2008
crisis but that's not with like a
well-run system is supposed to be it's
okay and uh it's a systemic thing you
know probably by the way one thing I
think about you know it's there's a
Libertarian theory that I
um
I never got that in two but now I'm much
more into it and that's you know
basically the FED is serial killer right
if you go back in time probably if you
go and look at the mortgage crisis you
can find the Fingerprints of the fed and
probably every every crisis you can find
the fingerparts of the FED injecting all
this variability and then everybody else
dies in a bunch of bodies at the end of
the cliff and the FED keeps playing
their games interest rated up and
straight down and straight up and
straight down pretending that injecting
all this chaotic cyclicity and craziness
in is adding value somehow when it's
actually just joysticking you know the
system and they would never give up that
control
because it makes them feel important and
how could we not help people or whatever
right and the control will have to be
taken away and that's ubiquitous all
right let me pause here
so another piece that I think people are
interested in is the nation state versus
the state we just saw today uh Board of
Governor Ron DeSantis he gave a press
conference he said that he is going to
propose legislation to Outlaw the use of
cbdc's in the State of Florida both
domestic and foreign put aside for a
second whether he legally can do it or
not because I saw much a debate of that
on Twitter but this idea that like
some of these states may not wait for
federal guidance and they may actually
go against the nation's interests how do
you kind of balance that
well so one thing I've got a ton of
graphs on this but basically actually
let me show some of these ready so I've
been tracking this for a while and what
most people don't know is that
um the 10th Amendment has basically been
coming back okay so in the sense that
um States breaking away from the feds
well as you are an expert googler
am I
yeah
here we go so
um
first of all states have already been
breaking away from the feds you know
rather people to own hold and use you
know shall not be infringed right and
um
all right so states are setting their
own
um Sanctuary so Sanctuary state laws
these have been going on for a long time
and
um some of them are to the left and some
are to the right of the federal
government right and uh you know here
marijuana laws okay they differ uh gun
laws
abortion laws right all of that stuff
differs quite a bit from state to state
and it's getting more so right and
um the thing about this is you know here
is you know Wyoming legal Dow
recognition cholera first teach except
crypto for taxes Miami crypto Capital
world like crypto is a political issue
and states will literally split on
crypto as to whether they are Fiat state
or a crypto State like that's like a
fundamental difference in fact I
actually think in what comes after this
after the Fiat crisis I think you're
going to see a lot of the Fiat economy
all the derivatives and so a lot that
just melts down you know basically just
shall poof and I don't know who gets
what money and you have essentially
um Fiat States maximal Estates where
it's Bitcoin only and then crypto states
which have you know Bitcoin plus right
but all three of them will value Bitcoin
and we'll all like fight over it and
then the question is whether Bitcoin
itself
um see because gold I mean gold will
also be valuable in that world but as
like a state to state thing
uh Bitcoin itself then is going to
actually be under you know the serious
stress test and we'll see what happens
um
go ahead you're gonna say
no my uh I think my last question for
you is
um when you look at this entire
situation playing out
you're raising the alarm you're kind of
sounding the alarm you put the bit
signal up you've got people from all
walks of life that are starting to pay
attention to it
if you had to guess now 90 days a year
out whatever kind of time frame you want
how many people do you actually think
will listen
I don't know but I do know that at least
I feel that I did my duty
to warn innocent Americans that I mean
there's a tradition on both the American
left and right of being suspicious of
the American government
right where it's on the left when it's
cointel Pro and all these people
wiretapping and so on or if it's on the
right you know when it's like don't
tread on me libertarianism right there's
a healthy suspicion of the state
and both left and right Libertarians are
within kind of our crypto community
and that's a strain of you know
americanism has been there for a long
time
and so you know essentially I think of
it as
you know there's basically four options
right one is
you just go back to sleep watch Tick
Tock don't do anything okay
two is
um
you this is a fall story you wire all
your money to a big Bank
now you think you're safe five percent
interest great a lot of people will fall
through the store because they just
don't get it
then the Trap shuts in like July or
whenever the cbdc and then they cannot
withdraw their money and they're stuck
and they're like I trusted them no right
and that's you know right then third you
get to bitcoin at least some you're
hedged right you're hedged into Bitcoin
but fourth you want to also be in a
Bitcoin friendly jurisdiction because
otherwise you're going to have problems
being in a in a in a having Bitcoin when
everybody else doesn't right
um and so I don't know what like of the
people where they land at one two three
and four
so I think that's fantasy
what um I I lied I actually have one
more question for you sure of course
what is the one what is the one thing
that you're looking for moving forward
what is the Milestone what is the data
point what is the thing that you'll be
like yes this thesis is on track uh if
you see it happen is it more Banks
failing is it you know more QE balance
sheet expansion like what are you
looking at
well the thing is the way they're
they're doing this printing the question
is whether or not we actually see with
the they have managed to get it to the
system to the point that people are
scared about whether their money's in
the bank and they print it to make sure
that if you come and do a bank run and
you move your money that you still have
it so the the
um the fundamental thing would be I mean
certainly the Bitcoin price going up
would you know we'll see when it if and
when it starts mooning right and
um and maybe people need to get their
wires to exchanges or something like
that but finally it's going to be
individuals and then it's going to be
um firms and then it's going to be uh
you know like funds and then eventually
it'll be I think small sovereigns like
naive Kelly and Jack Dorsey
um getting involved would be pretty
important
um because they also have a pretty big
megaphone and whatnot
and there's a feedback effect because
the more the price of Bitcoin goes up
and it's now shown the true decoupling
if you saw that right it's finally
decoupled from all the other assets
um so and we're talking about people
moving huge amounts of money at once
right they're moving their like entire
bank accounts right so those are large
purchases and a large percentage I'm not
saying you know it obviously it depends
on each person and what their percentage
is and so
um
you know you obviously need to pay your
bills and Fiat don't you know don't
invest something foolish or what have
you but it's it's it's something where
you should just hedge hedge what you can
and again it's not about like making
money
um it is about not losing money about
saving money it's just it's the flip of
what people you know how people think
about these markets so it's it is it
actually is much closer to the Maximus
worldview you know so anyway let me
pause there
blushy I appreciate you doing this I
know that you and I both are exhausted
and uh probably gonna fall asleep since
we hang up so I appreciate you taking
the time to do this I think there's a
lot of people who are very interested in
uh in your views and uh uh if anyone is
not following you on Twitter they
absolutely should and we'll definitely
do this in the future
all right thank you sir